hello miss dollar credit guy remember it
so you don't have to hey you remember a
kid in King Arthur's Court yeah
you ever wonder what the director of
that movie did before he made that
little masterpiece well not that much
give really top I kidding King Arthur's
Court but he did manage to direct a few
films before it one of them surprisingly
enough starring Hulk Hogan
this is mr. name why do wrestlers
continue to punish themselves by being
in movies they just so rarely work and
Hulk Hogan is the prime example event I
mean you thought suburban commando was
bad then at least had a few cute seams
this is just the ass shavings of what
was popular at the time home alone
slapstick top-secret plot devices family
life lessons and big tough stars doing
silly goofy things all that's missing is
a pet Chihuahua with sunglasses but hey
what good does it do to bitch about it a
lot but I reviewed to do so let's take a
look at mr. name so as the credits roll
we see that Hulk Hogan is having
nightmares about back when he was a
wrestler probably like how nowadays he's
having nightmares about this journey he
wants up to be greeted by a character
named Burt who I'm guessing just moved
on up from the east side to finally get
a piece of the pot I just got a call
from major major new clan he's looking
for a bodyguard not a bodyguard I'm a
wrestler I am a wrestler actually I
think this is how the offer for the
movie went down too I want you to do
this movie no I'm a worse one exactly
you're an actor why should all the rest
about the same thing so of course he
takes the job as he goes to meet up with
his rich client max from the Muppet
movie you're asking him to do something
terrible I can't be a part of it
you think you're going I'm working for
mr. Mason
get off the bike before just do it
Butthead whoa forget it
are you deaf or just plain stupid
neither I'm blonde just got a real low
tolerance for gorillas and rent-a-cop
suits to just call me down you're not on
American Gladiators and even if you wear
I probably get cancelled it's just a
buddy card Oh terrible mistakes are
rough I'll get rid of him he's
incredible obviously a real yes only a
real pro will loses temper throw a
rampage and be totally impossible to
control I see this working well where's
Mason's office so we see the reason he
hires Hogan is because he's getting
attacks and phone calls from your
average psychotic criminal genius who
the hell are you just your average
psychotic criminal genius you think it
says that US business card I desire your
new computer chip yeah there's a
top-secret computer chip in this movie
apparently there's information on a gun
that can shoot any kind of missile
imaginable is it me or is this sounding
like a story a ten-year-old boy would
come up with and there's an evil genius
who want the top-secret microchip second
shoot down missiles by using mr.
Freeze's gun and then whoa Colgan comes
in but he's wearing it to do anything
all girly and then mr. Jefferson comes
in because my mom really likes the
Jefferson Sam would like to see him in
my movie film Oh Sam you're supposed to
guide my kids oh you're out of your mind
I hate kids listen the children have a
nanny all you have to do is protect them
so he meets the two little kids one
named Kate and the other named Alex why
swear to God is a heavier version of the
kid from Kazan isn't he apparently miss
kopalski a short circuit in a blow dryer
oh this is very bad now the agency won't
send us any more nannies
so now Hogan has two jobs bodyguard and
nanny
hey mr. nanny if you will follow the
idea of a male nanny nowadays haha
Posterous but it's okay he has help from
the main played by an actress named
mother Locke who obviously shouldn't
have
name what are you doing in my kitchen
I'm Sean Armstrong here make yourself
useful - yup
lurch oh just put a bow on her and call
her precious no not that precious but
that was a good movie so he enters his
room where he sees a wire was
mysteriously laid out across the floor
here you will see the whole Cogan trying
his best to turn his primitive wheels
and overcome the obstacles of everyday
appliances the everyday appliances win
so yeah as you may have guessed the kid
set up traps all along the house warm
like I said home oil was very popular at
the time are you alright
never better dude that looks fucking
glass that's not funny you should go to
a hospital I'll tell you what after we
eat why don't we all go out and get some
ice cream yeah dad your beacon oh it's
my douche a meter
it says I'm to neglect you kids and let
you down until the climax of the movie
well can't fault an overused formula
later come on cake so even though the
father is never around and the mother
died of the fatal off-camera disease we
see the kids managed to keep some
hobbies
till didi to stay out of my own so after
the kids annoy him some more Hogan talks
with Burt to see if he can get out of
the job again listen to this and tell me
they're not talking about Hogan acting
in this movie you wanna spend the rest
of your life getting your brains kicked
in suit yourself but let me pull you in
on something extra Spurs on exactly in
demand you know I mean who else won't
help you a career kind of eerie isn't it
so it turns out the kids are devising
more traps that even Jonny Quest
couldn't figure out as they hook up a
giant bang into the ground it's funny
cuz he almost died
you know there's a difference between
pranks and attempted murder I mean Jesus
kids this is some creepy shit okay I
guess it's not that Patton crankin okay
okay that didn't happen but I might as
well these kids are sick it's not like
in other movies where the kids are just
defending themselves this is disturbing
really really disturbing I mean it's
like these kids are saito masochists or
something we just going to bite right
through man almost killed Sean are you
gonna punish it they want to be punished
alright I'm not gonna read any more to
this than I need to though something
tells me I'm gonna need to the two kids
go to school as hocum realizes that alex
is being picked on by a pair of bullies
all the time
yeah because he can take on a seven-foot
bodybuilding wrestler but put him up
against the human mullet and the kid
with sweaters are knit bys mentally
insane grandma and he chickens the fuck
act hey boys you only make it worse
dumbass kid you have a fucking Hulk
Hogan and you don't even know what
they're doing up that is unless they
consider drowning him in a pool of red
dahlias using him productively that's
right oh my god this is a visual you see
on the bed of horror movie DVDs in fact
this is a perfect time to introduce you
to a new part of the show
this is where I take a certain part of a
movie that's already a little creepy and
slow it down to make it even creepier
with that said let's take a look at this
scene in slow-mo yeah your pants be a
lot heavier don't they so who can
decides to punish the kids for the first
time since their mother died much to
their disturbing delight
hi Alex I hate being punished we
originally wanted whips and chains but
he thought the couch was much more
fitting so of course he starts bonding
with the kids as he shows Alex had to be
much tougher and sings a lullaby to Kate
mommy did you see me as someone could
you see it to me got a terrible voice
Shane Oh Jane I think this needs another
scary slow hmm okay okay you have enough
nightmares for the week but
unfortunately the father is kidnapped by
that average psychotic criminal genius
as Hogan invites burnt over to quote
unquote double security because
nothing's more threatening than a black
yo somebody Sam you should have seen the
blood pumping out Oh
Hogan actually ends up telling the kids
white Bert has a limp leg as we cut to a
flashback
nice match champ now we can pay the
hotel and get your clothes back Oh throw
that match
he looks like he's coming out of his
mom's vagina vagina
okay now we've gone from scary slow-mo
to a really dumb see so Hogan chases him
down and is a new organ playing I will
survive
Oh
it's a stupid play can somebody keep
your shit away from me
my stupid film I should go and soon it
flips I will survive Becca so the two of
them continue to watch the kids backs as
alex is again approached by the school
bullies he's got to do it on his own
did mommy put this on a string so Alex
want to lose any more money don't you
talk about my mother
what you gonna do oh my god Who am I I
can hear colors my penis is numb up me
so in this movie's quest to emasculate
Hulk Hogan we now see him having a tea
party I'm wearing it too - why because
they thought it looked great on the
poster obviously don't move oh boy I
paid good money to see Hulk Hogan fight
in the tutu nobody interrupts my
swan-like recital don't make me get
majestic on your lips
you vicious brute yeah sure um sometimes
it's hard to be a little
what about him let's his box off its
Black Codes eat him alive business
before pleasure so we see that the name
of our villain is that owes no not that
one
this guy the vagina face guy who now has
a bowling ball for a head Thanatos
I should have known who else would
kidnap little children a lot of people
so after the family is intimidated by
friar schmuck we see Hogan accept a
ransom call demanding him to bring the
computer chip oh yeah cuz we wouldn't
wanna do anything stupid like tell the
police or anything this is clearly a job
for an ex wrestler a tattoo - anyone can
see that so he breaks into the place as
we partake in the movies clacks
uh yeah I think your hands will be about
as healthy as the Skywalker's family
after that stunt oh don't you dare touch
that dangerously unbalanced woman
hangout will be baby no more this is
making me beg for the comedic genius of
three ninjas oh yeah remember those
nightmares from the beginning
I guess fighting a metal lobe Geico
caveman is the only way to overcome them
hell am I looking at you know for film
with the premise about a male nanny I
really didn't expect some of this
imagery so the bad guys destroyed the
families of course one again and Hogan
goes to spread his endearing love of
children somewhere else
ah
job is over
gonna settle down I'll find the little
shack by the railroad track only out so
that's mr. nanny what a surprise
it sucks there's little to no jokes that
weren't the characters are pretty much
just puppets and it's just another in
those long line of cheap kids films
about the big tough guy who has to look
after little tough children Hogan I love
you but if you want to make people laugh
go back to reality TV or wrestling
they're both equally fake
I meant Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have Bailey gonna call you
bro
when the going gets rough
you had enough
nothing but a powder puff
see